[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيين يعودون الى
ديارهم بعد ان كانوا محتجزين لدى الروس
تزامنا مع اطلاق سراح هؤلاء الجنود الروس
من السجون الاوكرانيه في المجموع تبادلت
كل من اوكرانيا وروسيا نحو 200ي اسير حرب
من الجانبين في احدى اهم عمليه تبادل
للاسرى خلال عامين من جهته تعهد الرئيس
الاوكراني باعاده كل الاسرى سواء كانوا
مقاتلين او مدنيين
تم اليوم اطلاق سراح 207 اوكرانيين اسرى
كانوا محتجزين لدى الروس من بينهم 180
جنديا و27 ضابطا انا سعيد بهذه
العمليه سنفعل كل ما في وسعنا لاعاده كل
الاسرى تاتي هذه العمليه بعد اسبوع من
تحطم طائره عسكريه روسيه في ظروف غامضه
مما اسفر عن مقتل جميع ركابها وتبقى
العديد من اسي دون اجوبه حول هذا الحادث
تقول موسكو ان الطائره كانت تقل جنودا
اوكرانيين واتهم الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اوكرانيا باسقاط الطائره عن طريق
صواريخ باتريوت التي كانت واشنطن قد
ارسلتها الى
كيف الطائره اسقطت وهذا ما تم التاكد منه
تم اسقاطها بواسطه نظام باتريوت
امريكي نحن نصر على اجراء تحقيق دولي في
اسقاط الطائره لا توجد منظمه دوليه مستعده
للمشاركه في التحقيق وفي تصريحات سابقه لم
ينفي المسؤولون الاوكرانيين بصراحه
الروايه الروسيه للاحداث لكنهم شككوا فيما
اذا كانت الطائره تقل فعلا اسرى حرب
اوكرانيين ميدانيا تستمر موسكو في الضغط
على انظمه الدفاع الاوكرانيه خصوصا في
دونباس وحول ادفي فكا مركز المعارك وتشهد
هذه المدينه الصناعيه منذ اشهر اشتباكات
بين الاوكرانيين والروس مما ادى الى وقوع
خسائر فادحه بحسب مراقبين